Welcome back. In this video we are going to take a look at how we can do some sort of bivariate
analysis using Excel. We've already taken a fairly detailed look at how we can do arithmetic using
Excel and how we can extend that arithmetic to do univariate analysis on continuous as well as
discrete columns. Here let's take a look at what happens when we try to do bivariate analysis. Now
as we know in order to do bivariate analysis we are going to need two columns either a pair of
continuous columns or a continuous and a discrete columns. So let's start with a pair of continuous
columns which is sepal length and sepal width. So we know that one of the most useful graphical
ways of checking correlation or essentially independence between two continuous variables
is to look at a scatter plot. So we have selected these two columns and since scatter plot is a
chart we can just go to the insert tab over here and then click on this particular
button here which simply says x y scatter. So we just click on this and there we have it. This is
basically the scatter plot of sepal length versus sepal width and you might have expected that
if sepal length grows then sepal width also grows but that doesn't seem to be the case over here.
In fact if you look at this blob here what that tells us is that there is no increasing or
decreasing sort of a strict relationship. Now that is something that we have inferred by simply
looking at this particular plot. We still do not have a quantitative idea of how much correlation
there is between the sepal length and the sepal width and of course we have a formula directly
to compute it which is called simply Corel and there we just say that we want to give it an array
basically a pair of arrays array 1 and array 2 and it's going to compute the correlation between
them. So let's say that I want to fill in my array I can just click on a over here so if it fills in
a colon a for us and then I put a comma space and then I click on b which is b colon b and I finish
the parenthesis and I press enter. So that's basically the correlation between sepal length
and sepal width and surprisingly you see it's actually it has a negative sign which means that
there is negative correlation between the sepal length and sepal width which means that as one
increases the other doesn't increase it decreases and even that relationship even the decreasing
relationship between them is very small because the magnitude tells us that it's a very small
magnitude it's in fact 0.08 which means that the extent to which one decreases as the other
increases is very small and the sign basically tells us whether it's an increasing relationship
or a decreasing relationship and now we what we graphically saw from this we basically saw that
there is almost no correlation these are mostly randomly scattered values that is reflected by
the very tiny value of correlation that we're getting here and basically as one increases the
other decreases that is not something we could have inferred by simply looking at this so that
is given by the mathematical quantity the negative sign tells us that there is and there is a
decreasing relationship. Now petals are a far more you know important characteristic of a flower and
you might expect that bigger petals mean that as a petal length increases the petal width also
increases so we might expect to find positive correlation between these two columns let's try
that as well let's select the petal length column and also the petal width column then go back to
the insert tab click on the xy scatter menu select the scatter plot and there it is that's basically
the scatter plot of petal width versus petal length and we see that you know there is a fairly
linear trend over here of course there is a cluster over here and there is another cluster
over here as you might have guessed these clusters depend on the species so this is basically
one species and this is a combination this large cluster that we see over here is a combination
of the other species now graphically again looking at this might lead us to believe that
there is a very high positive correlation between petal width and petal length but in
order to actually verify this value let's also try and do the correlation and we have the first
array which is petal length which is the c column so we say c to c and then we say d to d for petal
width and then we press enter and we get a value of 0.96 so the magnitude of the value which is
very high indicates that there is indeed a very strong correlation between petal length and petal
width obviously as one increases the other also increases and that increasing relationship is
given to us by the positive sign and there is a very high correlation so the relationship between
them is very dominant so this is broadly how we do bivariate analysis between a pair of continuous
variables we draw a scatter plot and we look at the correlation so we have the graphical and the
mathematical aspects both covered with excel however we still haven't considered what we can
do when one of our variables is categorical and the other is a numerical variable as you remember
from the previous video what we do in this case is something called grouping and aggregation you
group any particular continuous variable let's say something like petal width by each unique
value of species that occurs and then you try to do some aggregation on that individual group
the easiest way to do this in excel is something called a pivot table so let's select an empty cell
go to the insert tab and then we click on pivot table so that basically asks us to select a
table or a range now the table that we want to consider is basically this one so it's all the
sepal length sepal width petal length petal width and the species column and we want to essentially
insert this into the existing worksheet we don't want to create a new file so we leave this
particular option selected and then we click on okay and that basically gives me my pivot table
over here now in order to populate this pivot table i can look at this menu over here now here
what i say is that along the rows of this pivot table i want species so basically i drag species
from the field day menu over here into the rows menu over here and that gives me all the row labels
sir to sir versiculum and virginica and the blank are basically because we have values that are
extending beyond the row 139 as well we can ignore that one and then we say that the values that i
want are say the sepal length so i drag the sepal length down to the values colon and you see that
it says that it's giving me the sum of sepal length now what if we don't want the sum of
sepal length well i can just right click on this particular element over here and i can go to field
settings and here it basically says that sum of the sepal length is the field name and it is
summarized by sum however i can change it to average to count max min anything i want so let's
take average for now so that's basically average and as you see the field name changes to average
of sepal length and then i click on okay so what this means is that for setosa flowers the average
sepal length is this much for versicular the average sepal length is that much and for virginica
it is that much now of course i can do the same with all other values that is all other types of
numerical columns so this is one case of bivariate analysis i have taken one particular
categorical column i have taken another numerical column and i have applied some sort of
aggregation on that column which in this case is the average i can add the sum as well so let's say
i want to simply click on this again and that gives me my menu back i say not only i want the
average but i also want the sum so again i can drop sepal length into the values menu over here
and here again i get the sum let's remove the sum for now because anyway
it's not going to help us much so let's say i can just right click on the values field again
and do a remove field so i can also drop sepal width i can drop petal length i can also drop
petal width so here is my entire pivot table where i say that i have against the setosa species the
average sepal length the total sepal width the total petal length and the total petal width
now of course like we demonstrated earlier we can change these aggregations from sum
to average so basically let's or basically sum to anything else so let's say i click on this
i right click on this and then again i go to field settings and when i look at this i can
just do an average and i can do basically this becomes my average again here i can right click
on the sum of petal length i can go to field settings again and then i can do a minimum
instead of a sum or an average so basically that is my minimum value so there it is we have basically
one categorical variable we have four numerical variables and we have four different aggregations
specified against all of them so this is something that lets me perform bivariate analysis
when both my columns are of a different type that is one is categorical versus other is numerical